Kennedy was assassinated elevating Vice
President Lyndon Johnson to the White
House
journalist max Holland tracks the 36th
President of the United States with
transcripts of his conversations on the
Kennedy assassination the ensuing Warren
Commission and its aftermath the Kennedy
assassination tapes is this week's
history on book TV feature it's 45
minutes
good evening everyone and welcome to
Bynes an oval of Georgetown in tonight's
featured book the Kennedy assassination
tapes longtime Washington journalist max
Holland presents a momentous the
momentous telephone calls of President
Johnson that he made and received as he
sought to stabilize the country and keep
the government functioning after the
assassination of John F Kennedy each
page of the Kennedy assassination tapes
allows us to be the proverbial fly on
the wall in the Oval Office as President
Lyndon Johnson wrestles with the
personal and political transition of
leadership inside the White House max
Holland is an award-winning journalists
who has worked in Washington DC for more
than 20 years his articles have appeared
in many major newspapers including the
Washington Post Los Angeles Times and
Boston Globe we're pleased to welcome
him to discuss the Kennedy assassination
tapes and please help me welcome max
Holland I thank everyone for coming here
I know there are a lot of events
competing for our attention these days
politics and baseball I got interested
in the Johnson tapes in about 1995 as I
was doing work on a history of the
Warren Commission most of the books on
the assassination or more or less
adversarial in nature arguing who done
it or who didn't do it I started a book
on the Warren Commission in the belief
that history alone has that explanatory
power to make sense out of the
assassination and its aftermath I soon
realized that the tape recordings which
began to be released in 1993 contained
information that you could not find
elsewhere if nothing else they were very
sobering lesson in the limits of writing
history from memoirs or documents alone
they're simply with some information on
the tapes you could not find elsewhere
they truly are as Lyndon Johnson called
them once history with the bark off
their what really happened
before it's been rinsed for public
consumption
now 1997 historian Michael Beschloss
published the first and what he called a
series of books on the Johnson
conversations my first reaction to that
book was I wish I had had that idea
because I thought it was a very good one
my second reaction was that he saved me
from doing a lot of work because
ironically although I did this book the
one part of my job I probably disliked
the most as transcribing conversations
transcribing interviews including my own
then I had a third reaction though when
I heard him talk about some of the
conversations in the book particularly
one from September 18 1964 because his
description of it was at odds with what
I believed to be the case of what
happened on that day he said this is
Beschloss being interviewed that Johnson
and Russel disbelieved the Warren Report
is most important finding which was that
a single bullet had traversed President
Kennedy and hit governor Connally and
therefore to the most important man in
the country didn't believe the Warren
Report from the get-go the implication
being if they didn't believe it then we
shouldn't believe it either Beschloss
was followed and succeeding years by
many other authors who've looked at the
conversations and who have likewise
misunderstood and misrepresented them I
believe so I decided to do this book as
sort of a prequel to my book on the
Warren Commission sort of correct the
record exercise but as I did it I
realized it told a very important story
which is the arc of Lyndon Johnson's
reaction to and knowledge about the
Kennedy assassination it shows how the
assassination cast a shadow over his
presidency and his administration that
easily equaled the shadow cast by
Vietnam the tape show that the
assassination weighed heavily on Johnson
as the Vietnam War did
and it puts into very stark relief a
quote that he told Doris Kearns Goodwin
when she prepared her biography in 1976
this is Johnson speaking I took the oath
I became president but for millions of
Americans I was still illegitimate a
naked man with no presidential covering
a Pretender to the throne an illegal
usurper and then there was Texas my home
the home of both the murder and the
murder of the murderer and then there
were the bigots and the dividers and the
eastern intellectuals who were waiting
to knock me down before I could even
stand up the whole thing was almost
unbearable now for the balance of my
talk I'd like to focus on a few select
conversations that I've chosen because
they're both very telling and also the
aught of the audio quality should be
good enough for you to discern the words
not all the conversations unfortunately
are that clear but these I believe will
work the Air Force one tapes from
November 22nd because some of the
earliest tape recordings are from Air
Force One and the ride back from Dallas
to Washington are the audio equivalent
of the Zapruder film that is if JFK dies
anew before our eyes every time we see
the Zapruder film when you listen to the
tapes it's akin to hearing the news for
the first time the first tape I'm going
to play is of Pierre Salinger also known
as wayside his Secret Service codename
talking to the Situation Room a Navy
commander named Oliver Hallett it shows
the chaos in the highest reaches of the
United States government the lack of any
preparation for such a contingency and
at the same time it shows why this very
painful transition came to be regarded
as Lyndon Johnson's finest hour
[Applause]
[Applause]
Rajaratnam now am i blade
[Applause]
situation-room I read you go ahead all
available information on president
follows Connell town he and Governor
Connally of Texas have been hit in the
car in which they were rioting we do not
know how serious the situation is we
have no information mr. Bromley Smith is
back here in the Situation Room now we
are getting our information over the
tickers situation in your last
Roger would you wish information as to
whether some members of that party
should go to Dallas do you have anything
else the president was hit in the head
that just came in over Roger
[Applause]
[Applause]
I understand
hold on the line there way side we have
some more information coming up
[Applause]
[Applause]
Wayside Waifs i this is the Situation
Room I read from the people at Kennedy
apparently shot in head he fell facedown
in back seat of his car blood was on his
head
mrs. Kennedy cried old no and tried to
hold up his head Connally remained half
seated it slumped to the left there was
blood on his face and forehead the
president and the governor were rushed
to Parkland Hospital near the Dallas
trademark where Kennedy was to have made
a speech over this is Situation Room I
have nothing further for you now I will
contact you if we get more now I don't
have time to play the tapes that show
how an Albert forgotten vice president
has the full tonnage of the federal
government fall on his shoulders but
that is one of the most important
stories in the first days of the Johnson
presidency the second story that's of
great importance is the formation of the
Warren Commission and this is
particularly why history with the
barkoff is interesting because if you
were to read Johnson's memoir you would
think that from his description of the
Warren Commission that he the idea was
relayed to him after Oswald was killed
on November 24th he immediately thought
it was a good idea and thought about
appointing the Commission said about
doing so that's far from what actually
happened the next conversation is
between Bill Moyers a Johnson aide and
Eugene Rostow the Dean of Yale Law
School
Rostow was calling Moyers to suggest
what becomes the Warren Commission this
is on Sunday just a few hours maybe 45
minutes or less than a few hours 45
minutes and after Oswald has been
declared dead Rostow understands as few
Americans do the importance of a
purgative effect of a trial of due
process and now the due process has been
denied for Oz
there has to be some mechanism set up so
that the American people can experience
the satisfaction that a trial would have
brought he suggests a blue-ribbon panel
perhaps even putting Richard Nixon on it
then it's just now shaken by the
behavior of the Dalits believe that
they're not believing anything that's I
can understand that now I've got a party
here because I've been pursuing this
policy you know that people need to come
together at this time I know what you
could do that would be very helpful and
this is it this is a good suggestion and
I'll finish now in just a minute
bernasconi
[Applause]
excuse me go ahead well I was just
thinking coming in a few minutes ago
after hearing the news of our shooting
that this is symptomatic of what has
been happening into this country in the
last few years and the breakdown of
respect for law and order you know that
they decide impeach the Supreme Court
etcetera etcetera etcetera if I could
have a memorandum to give to the
president along these lines of one of
his great tasks is to help you know
continue the institutions that seem to
be at least if they have done it
outright at least weakened by if some
kind of sickness that has taken hold of
some parts of our population I'd like
him to have that to consider it if some
private talks he's having with newsmen
and with perhaps for a short session
next Wednesday night he needs to make
some point you know that that America is
known as a land of Public Order a land
of civility a land of in which the
public safety is guaranteed and there's
a very serious question right now in the
mind of the world about these
institutions that undergird tremendously
[Applause]
right now your suggestion is that he
appointed a special commission of
distinguished Americans primarily in the
field of law I presume to look into the
whole question of the assassination all
right report on it alright I'll get that
bill also I wish you would keep me
informed about how NICUs is it is doing
we don't want to put any greater strain
on him than is necessary but thank you
for calling out our follow through
goodbye now the idea of a special
commission is in turn entertained by
Lyndon Johnson but he had already set
the FBI in motion after Oswald was
killed while in Dallas police custody
and also state authorities and Texas had
launched an investigation all this was
on the advice of Abe Fortas who was a
Johnson advisor on political and legal
matters and he cautioned Johnson very
strongly and urged him not to let the
White House get involved in any
investigation of his predecessors murder
so Johnson took the position on Monday
against federal intervention in a state
matter and the reason that it had to be
prosecuted at the state level was as as
hard as it is to believe today killing a
president was not a federal crime not a
federal capital crime the most that
Oswald could have been prosecuted for
under federal law was an assault on a
federal officer carrying a maximum five
years in jail so you had the FBI and the
Texas State Attorney General involved
Johnson then learns on Monday to his
chagrin that his first significant
decision is being second-guessed he's
particularly upset when he learns that
the Washington Post is planning to have
an up an editorial which will call for a
federal Commission along the lines of
the one Rostow recommended so he calls j
edgar hoover hoping to enlist the FBI
director in influencing the washington
post not to make such a call the
washington post of course even then was
a very influential paper it's the paper
read in washington by all the
journalists who work here what hoover
says is very memorable he regards the
Washington Post as akin to the Daily
Worker which of course was the organ of
the u.s. coming
party to things
apparently some lawyer and justice is
lobbying or the post because that's
where the suggestion came from to for
this Presidential Commission which we
think would be very bad loaded right no
White House we can't be checking up on
every every paper country but they've
gone to the post now to get them an
editorial the post is calling up saying
they're gonna run in that door if we
don't do thanks now we're gonna do two
things
now I want youto fight one we believe
its way to handle this is as we said
yesterday your suggestion that you
whatever facilitates your command and
making a full report the Attorney
General and then that make it available
to the country in whatever form is the
scene may seem desirable hey loves per
second well you the state it's a state
matter to and that state attorney
general is young and able and further
and very cooperative with you he's gonna
run a court of inquiry which is provided
for by state law and he's gonna have
associate with him the most outstanding
curious a country but he's a good
conservative fella and we don't start
invading local jurisdictions that way
and he understands what you're doing and
he's part I want you to understand what
he was doing and and he's very strong
for it he's gonna announce it today now
if you get too many too many cooks mess
mother Bob it mess it up and and I think
that these two are trained organizations
and the Penta general estate holds ports
event cars over town allows violated and
the Justice the FBI it makes these
investigation so I want you to know that
he'll tell your press man that that's
what's happening and they can expect it
they can expect right in the car they
turn general text history bacon
announced but this morning yeah restate
in part and that the a long from here
full cooperation
vice versa he'll do it with you right
we'll wait for both like together and
any influence you got with a post to
have bought out door but you talk too
many things and it just picking out a
Tom's you a lawyer from here you're send
him down on the new facts this
Commission thing mr. mr. Herbert Hoover
tried bad if sometimes a commission
that's not trained hurts morning helps
it's a regular circus and that's right
we'll be colored by TV and everything
else Larkin investigated it already
exactly I I don't have much influence at
the booth because I just want your
people to know the facts and here people
can say that and that kind of negates
ERISA yes yeah I get look take
everything
Thank You McCready so then the question
is what changes Lyndon Johnson's mind
but because by Thursday Thanksgiving Day
he's calling people and announcing his
appointment of the Warren Commission I
believe that there are two developments
first Congress begins to stir in action
the Senate Internal Security
subcommittee announces an investigation
this subcommittee was chaired by Senator
James Eastland who was your prototypical
southern senator he was very
anti-communist which was fine by Johnson
problem was that Eastland tended to see
communists everywhere if there was going
to be an investigation by the Senate
that also meant there would be
investigation by the house the House
Judiciary Committee which in contrast to
the Senate was extremely liberal and was
likely to try and look for a right-wing
conspiracy in Dallas and in the house an
American Activities Committee had also
announced an investigation so he had the
specter of competing congressional
committees each trying to outdo the
other get more headlines in what was
going to be an election year what made
it even more sensitive was that when
Oswald went to Mexico City some six
weeks before the assassination he had
been captured on routine CIA
surveillance of the Communist embassies
in Mexico City
now this was extremely secret sources
and methods techniques used during the
Cold War and of course the CIA was very
worried that these congressional
committees would compromise the facts of
what we knew about Oswald's activities
in Mexico City
not only that would be extremely
embarrassing to the Mexican government
because they cooperated in maintaining
that maintaining the surveillance on the
Communist embassies so the CIA was very
worried the State Department was also
very worried but the man who probably
does more to change Johnson's mind is
Richard Russell his mentor in the Senate
he's one of the few persons that Johnson
actually listens to on the tape
recordings most of the other people he's
cajoling or overpowering but when
Russell speaks Johnson listens and when
they have lunch on Tuesday I think to
someone to Johnson surprise he finds
Russell much more concerned about
exposure of CIA sources and methods than
he is about federal intervention in a
state matter now Russell was also a
southerner from Georgia he was the
leader of the southern bloc in the
Senate but he was much more worried
about the exposure of the CIA
so that serves to convert Johnson to the
Commission and in the next conversations
you find him in his fabled
persuasiveness the next conversation are
going to plays with Jim Eastland on
Thanksgiving Day
he's calling Eastland because he wants
to tell him to drop his investigation
because he's going to appoint the
Commission he neglects however to tell
Eastland that he's going to appoint Earl
Warren because he knows that would raise
Eastlands ire
situation
what's your committee plan to do on it I
didn't it was done I had this feeling I
don't know it's very confidential I have
proposed it to anybody and I don't know
that it would but we've got pretty
strong state rights question here and
I've had some hesitancy to this start
having a bunch of congressional
inquiries and the violation of a state
statute and it might make it oh yeah I
know it's a low and it might set a
precedent you wouldn't want to have I
talked to some of the fellows body day
before yesterday Russell low down here
for lunch now my thought would be this
if we could do it we might get two
members from each body see we're gonna
have three in choirs running as it airs
and if we could have two congressmen and
two senators and maybe a Justice Supreme
Court take the FBI report and review it
write a report and do anything they felt
like needed to be done I think it would
this is very explosive thing and could
be very dangerous thing to the country
and a little publicity to disband the
flames
what would you think about what would
you think about that if we could work it
out of getting somebody from the court
somebody in the house somebody the
Senate have real
high-level judicial study of all the
facts alright I'm not worried about you
committee I know what you've here you've
had a committee okay much but I don't
know if you notice but he turned the
states rights argument on its head
whereas before he'd used it to argue
against federal intervention now he was
tellin where you're gonna have all these
congressional committees looking into a
state matter and doesn't that go against
your ideology now the conversation with
Richard Russell the next day in which he
tells Russell he's going to be on the
Commission is fascinating it's a great
lesson in Johnson's ability to cajole
bully and get people to serve even when
they don't want to Russell frankly
detests Earl Warren he doesn't want to
serve on the Warren Commission for the
duration it's not called the Warren
Commission and Richard Russell Senate
office it's the President's Commission
or the assassination committee it's
never called the Warren Commission in
Russell's office but unfortunately that
conversation is a little too long but
it's easily the test iasts conversation
between the two men and Russell finally
although he's very angry at being
sandbagged by Johnson recognizes that if
he doesn't serve if he renounces the
announcement that Johnson has made that
he's going to be on the Commission he'll
be a very severe blow to his disciple so
ultimately he does agree to serve now
there are other tapes that show a side
of Johnson that we don't often see that
I consider assassination related and
some of these have to do with Jack
Jacqueline Kennedy
I'd like to play one for you right now
in the immediate aftermath of the
assassination Johnson has numerous
conversations with the former first lady
and they show aside for of him that the
American public I don't think really
ever sees
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
despite our promise to come visit
Johnson the white house she actually
never does and Johnson takes this very
personally although I don't believe it
had anything to do with him it was
simply too painful for her to come back
the first time she does come back is
during the administration of Richard
Nixon nonetheless this sends a lot of
tongues wagging in Washington the idea
is that cheese is alienated from the
Johnson's as Robert Kennedy is now the
Warren Commission and the investigation
of the assassination is not the topic of
many conversation in the ten months that
the Warren Commission meets but there is
one very important conversation from the
September 18th 1964 I referred to it
earlier this is the conversation between
Russell and Johnson it's on the day that
the Warren Commission meets for the last
time and the reason it is so important
is because there's almost no other
contemporary contemporaneous record of
what transpired that day Warren
considered the Warren Report akin to
Brown versus the Board of Education he
wanted the unanimous report but he
didn't want to let the American people
see what they had to do in order to get
there
akin to the American people not knowing
how the Supreme Court justices reaching
Animus decision and a Supreme Court
verdict so there is no minutes of the
last meeting
although minutes had been taking of all
the previous sessions so this
conversation between Johnson and Russell
is extremely significant because it
shows Russell's reservations about the
Commission and what he did to change the
language now in Beschloss is rendition
and one of the things that struck me
about it was he is the words little old
threat meaning that Warren threatened
Russell in some with some unknown
consequences if he'd assisted from
signing a unanimous report what Russell
actually says as little old thread
because he came in with some dissents
and warned because he wanted a unanimous
report massaged the language until
Russell had no ground to dissent on and
that was what was said not that Warren
issued a threat against Russell that had
happened I believe all hell would have
broken loose the other aspect about this
conversation though that's very
important has to do with the single
bullet conclusion this is another of
Russell's dissents he doesn't believe
that a single bullet passed through
President Kennedy before hitting
governor Connally now he hadn't studied
this aspect very carefully his main
concentration insofar as he worked on
the Warren Commission was to look for a
communist conspiracy when he didn't find
one his interest waned dramatically so
he didn't believe this because Conley
insisted that he'd been hit by his own
bullet and world should Russell wasn't
going to have Earl Warren's commission
contradict the word of an honorable
southern governor even though it made no
sense and when he says I don't believe
in it because it doesn't matter well it
couldn't have mattered more and when
Johnson says I don't believe in it
either it's just an example of Johnson
speaking for effect he doesn't even
understand what the issues are and this
has been destroyed
by writers about the assassination and
Johnson to suggest that the two to the
most important men and the government
didn't believe in the Warren Report from
the get-go superficially that's true but
it's also very untrue to suggest the
plane came home I didn't bring a shirt I
got few little things why do you rush
they'll take another hour and go on gets
closed well they tried to prove it was a
bullets idiot Gary the place but the one
that hits Carly went through him through
his hand is falling into his leg
everything else there's a lot of stuff
sitting here all the ever since college
exam and all but I did read the record
and
so I just I don't know I was on the
fella that I didn't in fact that she
gets any case what happened what
Stafford got about as a stamp it just
always scares me I like to put my only
you down oh we've got you pretty good
report
well what if Sigma quits Butler Connelly
well it's all make much difference but
they said that they believe that the
committee for the Commission believe but
the same bullet that hit it got me well
I don't believe it
I don't and so I couldn't sign it and I
a static govern comment if I direct to
the contrary I'm not gonna prove that so
I finally made them say there was a
difference in the Commission in that
order believed that wasn't true and what
if a fella with actors melted Canada
rising next on one shot knocking it off
next and when he leaned up here is if I
have said not he mooned uh well he
didn't miss completely with that statue
off according to that theory not only
missed the whole bill but he missed the
streets but a man who couldn't have shot
to put two bullets right if he can't he
didn't miss that all automobile and all
the streets anyhow that just little
things
David then they did it for any reason
well just a general misanthropic fella
that he's had never been satisfied
anyway was on earth did unless you're
here and that is to get his name in
history at all I don't think you'll be
this pleased with reporters too long but
it's a full-body inanimate yes but
they'd come around trade me out if I
give me a little bread every day now
moved to the fall of 1966 mm-hmm very
significant time for Johnson up until
now the transition had been seen as his
finest hour the Warren Report was
accepted more or less as the last word
on the assassination but beginning in
the summer books critical the Warren
Report began to be published two of whom
two of which are bestsellers the
criticism of the report ranges from the
deserve because the Warren Report wasn't
a perfect document to the dishonest
strikingly Johnson believes that Robert
Kennedy is behind the criticism this
comes out in a conversation with Abe
Fortas in October 66 one of the most
recent conversations released by the
Johnson library I thought I had heard
everything until I heard this
conversation but then Johnson blames
Robert Kennedy because he believes that
Robert Kennedy is attempting to put his
first decision in a bad light and if the
Warren Commission didn't get to the
bottom of the matter it's going to
reflect on Lyndon Johnson so the report
starts to come under attack
then another development early in the
fall around Labor Day rumors begin to
circulate about a book by William
Manchester
and it's a very striking book today
perhaps it wouldn't be so striking but
in those days to have a major publisher
like Harper & row violate the norms by
which presidents were treated was very
remarkable Johnson was depicted in the
book which was the Kennedy's official
history of the assassination or
authorised history as an unworthy
successor a usurper someone who grabbed
the accoutrements of power hastily he
insisted on being sworn in before the
plane left Dallas he insisted on moving
into the Oval Office the next day he was
inconsiderate of Jacqueline Kennedy
literally dragging her out of her
stateroom so she could be photographed
next to him in that very famous picture
aboard Air Force One finally and most
unfairly Johnson is depicted as the
personification of the Texas forces
responsible for the assassination
violence and extremism the stories this
story is told in conversations that
Johnson has with Bill Moyers and Abe
Fortas from December 66 they're very
long conversations his aides wanted a
counter-attack in the press by leaking
accounts that would be favorable to
Johnson to show how kindly he treated
mrs. Kennedy as evidenced by that
telephone call earlier but the offense
to Johnson prize is immeasurable his
very being as a politician is under
attack it's existential in nature and
his frustration is particularly evident
in a conversation he is with Bill Moyers
on the day after Christmas and I just
like to read very briefly from this one
of the allegations that Manchester is
allegedly going to publish because the
book doesn't come out until the spring
of 1967 is that Johnson called mrs.
Texas
mrs. Kennedy honey and this is Johnson
almost shouting I never said to anybody
that I called her honey because that was
the Texas way I don't believe that's the
Texas way I think I would call people
honey because if I felt they were honey
and I might have very well said to mrs.
Kennedy although I never felt that way
about her and never believed it I have
held her kind of on a pedestal and been
very reserved with her as her letters to
me will indicate very proper very
appropriate very dignified very reserved
as I don't think I called mrs. Rose
Kennedy honey I think that's the
creature of someone's imagination how
can I not related when it just didn't
happen finally I'd like to draw your
attention to conversations from the
spring of 1967 when the other shoe drops
so to speak this is after months of
articles in the press following up the
books that have been critical the Warren
Report Life and The Saturday Evening
Post have major investigative stories
pointing up all the defaults or defects
in the Warren Report and finally a
hurdle for obscure district attorney in
New Orleans Jim Garrison announces that
he's reopening the case in February 1967
this of course causes a media firestorm
in New Orleans and what you see from the
conversations is a very intricate
interplay between this announced
investigation by a district attorney and
everybody believes because he's a
district attorney he has something
responsible to say about the
assassination and the story a rumor
Johnson has heard about assassination
plots against Castro now this was told
to him in January a month before
garrison announces his investigation at
first he tends to dismiss this story
it's as if he says someone came up to
him and told him the lady bird was
strung out on heroin he just refused to
refuses to believe that there were
assassination plots against Castro and
more importantly that these
assassination plots were done with the
full knowledge and even the direction of
Robert Kennedy the Attorney General at
the time and these two developments play
off one another until on March 2nd
there's a conversation between John
Connally
and Lyndon Johnson and which Connolly
talks about both the rumors and
Garrison's investigation and Johnson
tries to assure him that the FBI has
looked into both and believed there's no
there there but on March 2nd Jim
Garrison arrests New Orleans businessman
named clay Shaw and that in turn prompts
Drew Pearson to write a column about
this allegation now the column isn't
even printed in The Washington Post
because it's considered too scurrilous
it's unsourced it's just a rumor in fact
the column admits it's just a rumor but
nevertheless it is printed and many
other newspapers that subscribe to The
Drew Pearson column nationwide and
because of that column Ramsey Clark the
Attorney General under Johnson goes to
the FBI and asked them what they know
about this rumor which is now in print
about ten days later the FBI comes back
with a memo entitled CIA's intentions to
send hoodlums to Cuba to assassinate
Castro and now Johnson knows it's true
he turns to Richard Helms who's the
director of the CIA and was the CIA's
liaison to the Warren Commission and he
asked him I want to know about this now
what we don't know is whether Johnson
told him I've heard these rumors and
there was a story in The Drew Pearson
column I'd like you to tell me the truth
about them or were they told Helms I
know from the FBI this is true and I
want to know the whole truth whatever
the case in May 67 Helms comes back and
for an hour in a meeting that's
completely unrecorded tells Johnson the
whole truth about the attempts to
assassinate Castro including the
employment of the Mafia in these
attempts in the early 1960s who
authorized them in the Kennedy White
House so Johnson learns eight years
before the American people exactly the
truth about the plots to kill Fidel
Castro after that although Earl Warren
and Jagger Hoover and Richard Helms
tried to dissuade him otherwise Johnson
believes that President Kennedy was
killed in retaliation for these
assassination attempts and he goes to
his death
believing that now the importance of
that is that it depicts the arc of
Johnson's thought and reactions to the
assassination and it shows how important
the assassination was throughout
Johnson's presidency and that he didn't
into my mind just leave the presidency
because of Vietnam although that was
very important it's almost an article of
faith with historians that Johnson left
because McCarthy won unexpectedly large
percentage of the vote New Hampshire
primary and then Johnson fearing that he
would be contested for the Rinat nation
bowed out but I think if you look at
what Johnson understood to be the case
in 1968 that he knew that he replaced a
man who had been killed and he believed
in retaliation for the attempts against
Castro and yet he had picked up the
pieces he had followed through on
Kennedy's liberal agenda which Kennedy
himself had not been able to get through
the Congress he had passed Medicare
civil rights and other pieces of
legislation that had been stalled for
years if not decades and still Johnson
was not able to command the loyalty of
the liberal intelligentsia of the
Democratic Party
he felt that even even in Vietnam he had
pursued Kennedy's policy so while I
believe he was quite prepared to defend
his record against liberals who he felt
were betraying him in 1968 the
precipitating factor for his withdrawal
from the race was Robert Kennedy's
entrance it was the final straw and in
an interview with Doris Kearns he did
say exactly that and then the final
straw the thing I feared from the first
day of my presidency was actually coming
true Robert Kennedy openly announced his
intention to reclaim the throne in the
memory of his brother
and the American people swayed by the
magic of the name were dancing in the
streets the whole situation was
unbearable for me after 37 years of
public service I dilute I deserve
something more than being left alone in
the middle of the plane chased by
stampedes on every side that's the end
of my formal presentation be glad to
entertain any questions yes my question
would be my understanding is that there
was shortly before the Kennedy
assassination an interview that Fidel
Castro had with a journalist I think a
French journalist who and in that
conversation the attempts on Castro's
life were mentioned and Fidel Castro
said well American attempts on his life
and Fidel Castro said something to the
effect that well people that do these
things should be careful they can have
them the very same things done to them
right is that accurate
wouldn't how do you how would that fit
in with this right it is true that in
september 64 castro made that remark
I'm sorry 63 Castro made that remark and
after the assassination had took on this
ominous tone at first the people in the
National Security Council were very
dismissive of it I think what Castro
probably was meaning if he was going to
do anything was he would likely
retaliate it meant against American
ambassadors in Latin America and
probably target them for assassination
if there were continuous assassination
attempts against him or other members of
the Cuban government I think it would
have been reckless in the extreme for
him to trial II try to retaliate in kind
it would been much safer so to speak to
target American ambassadors and in fact
there is some evidence that he did think
about doing that
anymore Christian
while we thought with no other questions
we were one we're okay
tonight's book is the Kennedy
assassination tapes
Alfred cannot and please thank with me
max island everyone we will be signing
books right over here at this table and
I thank you very much
max Holland is a contributing editor at
the Nation magazine and the Wilson
quarterly the Kennedy assassination
tapes is published by Knopf visit Random
House dot-coms